je vais utiliser un autre sens laissons
par exemple là vous entendez je réalise
qu'elle déco donc le plafond n'est pas
très haut
la pièce est fait de matériaux durs par
terre on a du carrelage on n'a pas du
mur on a des carrelages au mur donc ça
ça me donnent déjà des indications
naturellement il n'y a pas de
technologie pour un architecte aveugle
bien fallu que je trouve beaucoup de
technique on va prendre ce plan va
mettre du fil de plomb autocollants va
être un peu comme du braille je vais
pouvoir toucher un peu tous mes plans à
l'âge de 32 ans benjamine et los angeles
j'étais dans la publicité de parfum je
vais un bureau à los angeles un bureau à
new york et murs à paris rentré de paris
et j'avais un peu un problème sur mon
oeil droit comme un espèce de rideau qui
descendait je vais voir un ophtalmologue
qui me dit qu g1 le cmv qui voulait rien
dire pour moi c'était le sictom égal au
virus c'est je lui demande de tout
simplement combien j'ai besoin de
lunettes j'ai besoin quoique lunettes il
dit ah non pas du tout c'est une
infection virale qui va vous rendre
aveugle et probablement vous tuer parce
que l'affection virale après montera au
cerveau journées de novembre le 5
novembre d'ailleurs je me réveille je
voyais plus rien là les racines j'avais
déjà une rétine qui s'était détaché la
deuxième rétine cdh
du coup je vois plus rien mes parents
étaient là puisqu'il savait que j'allais
petit à petit vers la fin mon médecin
avait annoncé leur avait annoncé que
j'avais une quinzaine de jours à vivre
mais voilà j'ai décidé que quelque part
que je n'ai pas fini ma vie que j'ai
quelque chose encore à faire mon système
immunitaire a commencé à re à
refonctionner à se battre contre ce
virus
j'étais aveugle certes mais j'avais
décidé de ce virus avait pas me tuer
souvent je pense que la vue nous nous
arrête sur des choses qui ne sont pas du
tout essentiel on va regarder un mur
sans penser à la possibilité que l'on
pourra enlever ce mur et ouvrir la
maison et moi je suis déjà dans l'âme
dans le le le
la possibilité de ce que ces maisons
pourraient être quand je rentre dans une
nouvelle maison que je connais pas du
tout je vais faire une espèce de
diagnostic donc je vais déjà me mettre
dans la première pièce dans laquelle
jour entre généralement l'entrée essayez
d'écouter contraintes sentir mon
environnement
une petit à petit je vais m'approprier
les maisons ont déjà en touche en allant
vers les murs en touchant naturellement
ben les matériaux l'espace pouvoir me
dire bon ben là qu'est ce que je
retrouve est vraiment m'imprégner de mon
environnement pour essayer dans mon
esprit de faire une carte un peu de
cette maison après je vais le dire bon
très bien maintenant comment je vais
pouvoir mesurer mon environnement
je me rappelle de l'homme de vitruve qui
en fin de compte nous donne d'opposition
cette position on croit qu'il est mise
dans un carré qui nous dit que ben de
mon doigt gauche à mon doigt droit je
retrouvais exactement ma hauteur je fais
un mètre 83 donc dans en prenant cet
exemple là je vais aller trouver le coin
de cette pièce met mon doit ouvrir mon
corps de cette manière voilà je trouve
un mètre 83
je prends mon dois-je le place ici je
continue mon mon expérience
mesurée j'estime un peu la distance donc
je me dis voilà on est à peu près 1 m à
3 à 3 mètres 90 du placard ce qui me
donne facilement une façon de pouvoir
mesurer où que je sois pluie dont les
sons je vais écouter par rapport à mon
environnement jeu tête entend le bruit
du frigidaire
après je vais utiliser les odeurs les
odeurs parce que tout à l'heure à des
odeurs que ce soit l'eau d'heure ben
d'une cuisine mais aussi le d'heure des
matériaux les l'odeur du fer l'odeur du
cuir
l'odeur de certains bois et tous ces
éléments vont m'apporter un peu les
épices les qui constitue un plat un peu
j'ai dû arrêter de travailler et rend
aveugle naturellement j'avais ce gros
problème c'est que je vais commencer ces
gros travaux sur ma maison à los angeles
sur les collines et que je devais la
finir et me sans même le savoir bain
tous ces points que ce soit à travers
les sons les sons du frigidaire lisson
de la rue ils sont du moteur la piscine
et ses odeurs devenait mes nouveaux
points cardinaux me permettait de me
demeura propriétaite maison du coup j'ai
pris la décision pain de la finir moi
même qu'est-ce que j'ai fait après je me
suis dit pourquoi pas essayer avec
d'autres maisons j'ai racheté des
maisons plus petit jeu refait la même
expérience et petit à petit je vendais
ces maisons plus cher que le prix que je
demandais la presse aux etats-unis s'est
aussi emparé de cette histoire de ma vie
de ce succès et bat énormément médiatisé
ce qui a aussi fait que j'ai pu
commencer à arriver à travailler avec
des gens
des gens très connus des stars
d'hollywood et plus petit à petit
progresser vers quelque chose qui est
devenu pour moi une grande fierté à une
passion également je crois que je
pourrais que ce soit dans l'
architecture mais que ce soit d'autre
chose je pense qu'aujourd'hui je rien
est impossible pour moi c'est une
question de perspective c'est une
question de volonté
c'est se dire quand il ya un problème
bas quelle est la solution
naturellement il y aura des barrières
mais si à des barrières il ya des défis
s'il ya des défis et des leçons de vie